we are in the home stretch problem
number 17
on page
463 oh i like these with these strange
operations let the operation
up arrow be defined as
a
up arrow
b
is equal to
a plus b
over a
minus b
for all numbers in a and b where a does
not equal b a does not equal b and why
did they have to say that well because
otherwise our denominator would be zero
if
so we know that one
up
two
is equal to
up x
what is x x equals
so let's set up the equation so what is
one up arrow two so that is we just use
this that's one plus two over one minus
two so it's one plus two
over one minus 2. i just use this
formula 1 up you know 1 is a 2 is b
right and that equals what's 2 up arrow
x that's 2 plus x
2 plus x
over 2 minus x
2 minus x
so 1 plus 2 is
1 minus 2
is negative 1 right
so it's negative 1
is equal to 2 plus x over 2 minus x
and of course this is just equal to
negative 3
right
and now we can multiply both sides of
this equation by 2 minus x because we
know that x can't be equal to 2 because
it says a can't equal to b
so we know we're not multiplying both
sides of this equation by 0
2 minus x right all i'm doing that's all
i'm doing i'm just multiplying both
sides by 2 minus x
and then i get
on the left hand side i get negative 3
minus 3 times 2 minus x
right and on the right hand side the 2
minus x's cancel out and i get 2 plus x
and then i distribute the 3
minus 6 plus 3 x is equal to 2 plus x
and let's see where do i want my x is
let's add 6 to both sides 3x is equal to
8 plus x subtract x from both sides 2x
is equal to eight x is equal to
four
choice a
okay problem number eighteen i'm gonna
switch colors too because this color is
not appealing to me
let's see green
18. looks like this this involves money
so green is good
18.
during a sale a customer can buy one
shirt for x dollars so
one for x
one shirt for x each additional shirt
costs
z dollars less than the first shirt each
additional shirt cost the customer buys
costs z dollars less than the first so
additional
z
less
than
first
then the first shirt for example the
cost of the second shirt is x minus z
all right fair enough which of the
following represents the customer's cost
in dollars for n shirts bought during
the sale
so n shirts
and shirts
so the first shirt is going to cost x
right the first shirt's going to cost x
and then how many shirts are left
well there's n minus one shirts
that aren't the first shirt right n
minus one shirts are you know they buy
one shirt at x and then they're gonna
buy n minus one at the at the other
price and then the other price is
x minus z right because all the other
and
they actually they're sl well they're
not ambiguous but you know it's not like
the third shirt costs z less than the
second and then the fourth shirt costs z
less than they all cost z less than the
first right so every other shirt costs x
minus z
so we have n minus one other shirts
right we had one it the first one costs
x then we have n minus one shirts that
cost
x minus
z dollars
and did they
draw write it like that yes that is
choice a
i thought maybe they might have
multiplied it out and we'd have to you
know look for something similar but they
gave it just the way it is
all right
next problem
problem number
okay
19. so they drew i don't need to draw a
draw neatly i could draw this thing
freehand
okay so this is p
30 degrees
q
and r
in the figure above qr is the arc of a
circle with center p if the length of q
r is 6 pi
so this is 6 pi
6 pi what is the area
of sector p so
this length is 6 pi so they want to know
what this area is
well this the the big important
realization is is that this is part of a
larger circle so if you know if i were
to draw the entire circle like that
and then i would draw let me do it in
different color
you know this this is part of
a larger circle
where this you know it's p
q
r
and 30 degrees
and this 30 degrees is important because
it tells us what fraction of the larger
circle this is well how many degrees are
there in a total circle well there's 360
right if we were to go all the way
around there's 360. so the fraction that
this is of the full circle is 30 degrees
over 360. and this is 1 12
1 12 of the internet you know i haven't
drawn to scale the way i do it it looks
more like 60 degrees but if you should
be able to draw 12 pi's of 30 degrees
here
right hope i'm not confusing you because
you're 360 degrees in the circle
so if this if this slice is 1 12 of the
whole circle
then this arc length this 6 pi
the 6 pi right here
6 pi
is going to be 1 12
of the entire circumference so what's
the circumference the circumference is
going to be 12 times this
so the circumference is 12 times 6 pi
which equals
what 72 pi
if the circumference is 72 pi
what is
the radius
what's the formula circumference is
equal to 2 pi
r so we could say that also is equal to
72 pi
so you could let's see divide pi by you
know divide both sides by pi and then
divide both sides by two
you have the radius is equal to 36
so this radius right here
this radius let me do a different color
this radius
is equal to 36 right all i did is i
figured out this arc length is 1 12 of
the entire circumference
and so the entire circumference is 72 pi
and then i use that to figure out that
the radius must be
now we want to know the area of just
this piece so we can just figure out the
area of the whole thing and then divide
by 12 because this is 1 12 the area of
the circle as well
so what's the area
area
is equal to pi
r squared
that equals pi
times 36
squared i'm going to write 36 times 36
because i don't want to multiply big
numbers
and then that's the area of the whole
thing is pi times 36 times 36. so the
area of just this fraction will be the
area of the whole thing
divided by 12
divided by 12.
and the reason why i didn't multiply it
out is because i can actually cancel i
could say well this is this is 3 this is
1.
so it's pi times 3 times 36 and what's 3
times 36 90 plus 18 is 108 so it equals
108 pi
which is choice
a
let's see if i could squeeze in
the last problem probably not
actually i will save the last problem
for a video of its own because i only
have a minute left see you soon